bootle cat podcast man go watch the full
interview we did with big X the plug 600
entertainment rosama's in the building
yeah Dallas Texas in the building FedEx
is in the building yes it's in the
[__] building
we're just gonna have my guy do what he
does roll summer
yeah
oh 30 on me now Julius Randle [__] I'm
at the top I [__] around and touch Jesus
Santa Cruz ice Rich refrigerated water
fountain but like the toilet won't flush
it's some [__] we got to handle like how
you come up with this where you rap I'm
just a black person when I hear a beat I
just snap new and reduction get your
hand tap or treat them like a [__] in
Iraq he get his [__] head rap
Cartier frames look like mirrors in a
mouth like veneers crystal chandeliers
hanging from my ears I've been balling
with this green pop fears scope on the
top camo shot look like we out here
took his legs off next time you think
smoked then it's air pollution
bad days
[Music]
oh
I appreciate you guys watching this
freestyle we got another one coming and
then another one and then another one
and they're all brought to you by our
good Folks at LRG clothing you already
know what it is LRG been keeping you fly
for years they got so much new fly gear
right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle's on the way
presented by LRG